[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for both Andrew and myself inexplicably
to both see superhero movie for the very
first time how you doing today man I'm
doing well I'm ready to finally get to
see a masterpiece of Cinema the holy
Grill of the superhero genre in a year
featuring Iron Man and the Dark Knight
one movie shown Supreme superhero movie
now we are going to be watching this for
the first time please leave a comment
below one letting us know how unlikely
that is to you cuz we're we're we're
sure it's coming two what your favorite
joke in this movie is because I'm
fascinated especially since this was
coming out right as the end of that era
was ending as we got into this current
ERA of superhero movies and three what
else you might want us to watch hit that
like so we know you liked it that thumbs
up fills me with lots of joy and also
thanks to our folks at prepper who
helped this very video exist if you want
to watch this video and entirety front
to back beginning to end with all of our
resting watching faces please head over
to patreon and become a super sexy
reject without further Ado it is time to
give to you superhero movie part two no
part one here we
go preparing you for the epicness with
this music the scope of Dimension films
oh wow I didn't know this was diens but
makes sense cuz scary movie right yeah
that
spoof
oh makes sense too I think uh David
Zucker was a producer for this as well I
like the the stainless steel text too of
the era as well it's Saron it's got that
uh Danny Elfman Spider-Man theme feel oh
100%
the I like that we already got to see a
zipper something you never see right
dude written directed by Craig Mason is
nuts I know who am I you sure you want
to know the voice of Spider-Man voicing
not Spider-Man actually I'm worse than a
nobody I'm this guy
[Laughter]
stop story of my life is not for the
faint of heart it's going to be
Spider-Man 2 on overdrive yeah 100% it's
all about a
girl not that
girl it's about this girl Jill Johnson
ever since I can remember looks familiar
I've been in love with Sarah Paxton oh
is that that is a young Sarah Paxton
good call come here man I got your seat
down here what's I call you back baby
Kevin har dude I'm so psyched for this
class trip like we about to see some
real serious cutting Ed
[__] that's what I'm talking about he's
still like 25 as a high schooler but hey
maybe also of the era I mean that's the
thing too A lot of them were older still
in high school yeah the CW was yeah oh
small stuff like that she not even
looking at you she's not looking I
already told you you never going to get
with
you product placement it's still true
she hangs out with a popular crew and
Nobody messes around outside that group
man look you got your
jocks nerds
Emos
fros yeah how big this bus is this is
great sexual predators oh my god oh wow
of course you got the ri
the
who yeah they knew
mhm you're the best
man am I in no come on it's me and you
baby two of us against the world you
hear me you look good today I like your
here something nasty I download it don't
tell
nobody all right little Oz Corb I'm Dr
St head of the research oh they call him
Dr St too and now I'd like to show you
our Crown Jewel The Amalgamated animal
genetic
SL closest we'll get to amalgam Universe
for another 10 years yeah you're so
pretty oh hi
birdie take her picture got to but with
a bird she's going to become bird girl
uh I'm I'm going to take a picture of
her for for the school newspaper our
only rules don't feed the animals and
please no flash
photography oh my God it flew
away this is one year after order to the
Phoenix 2o
is there a problem hey shooter mcavin
this is Lou Landers Visionary scientist
and CEO of Amalgamated Norman
[Music]
Osborne are you okay this is healthy
golf
blood Rick rker you're not bling Julia
ryker's son are you I am good people how
are they they died violently 9 years ago
but otherwise okay yes thank you I live
with my aunt and uncle now well you seem
like a real chip off the old block let's
hope you're not violently murdered
too good solid
advice e that's were making me look
stupid next time I hurt
you our work with these animals has
helped us develop new antibiotics and a
powerful new pheromone which drives
animals to mate called compound
h29 h29 a single drop is enough to
arouse any animal oh no
breeder powerful
phon my most promising research is with
these dragonflies oh he's dragonfly man
this species of dragonfly has enormous
sprank for its
size oh
God injected the DNA from all three
species into seven new Genetically
Enhanced super dragon flies there's only
six in there well uhoh this is how it
[Music]
happens this area oh
God they're all coming for him
now aren't you going to do something
soon as I get this up on YouTube it's
all about the views and the likes that
was the principal Rick walked off a
class trip after all the parenting is
this Leslie neelon is the uncle got to
be uncle bed
right have no idea
yes taught him everything I know about
being a man and a good man you are after
all these years of marriage your hair is
gray you have crows feet it takes you an
hour to
pee and you've always had a
tiny
well can't argue
that oh RI we were wondering where you
were o Purity is a difficult
time your mood swings fluid retention
and once a month you'll bleed from
your this may be the wrong book what's
important is that you're on the ver of
adulthood here take a
[Laughter]
drink I'm losing patience Dr Strong
please sir if you could just hey Homer
Simpson where the board of directors our
time is valuable c not as valuable as
mine Mr
Carlson that was great that was my
favorite joke so far yeah oh that was
fantastic I did not see that one coming
you didn't see that coming I have a
terminal illness I have 1 hour left to
live it was on
sale we can't afford a pet one a device
that can alter DNA and restore the body
to perfect health you're crazy crazy is
hearing voices talking to cats dating
Paula
Abdul so the machines never been fully
tested if something should go wrong the
machine looks like he's going to have a
labotomy plasma level steady genetic
modifications and Optimum levels we have
to
afford so escalated quickly did it work
I'm so sorry what a joy it will be
running this company without you in the
way let me
go
oh stole his life force he's like
vulture in those early 2000s late '90s
Comics yeah gentlemen I think it's time
we made some per Personnel
changes hope data's
[Laughter]
okay oh how long was I asleep 5
[Music]
days check your ABS that's the trick did
Drake Bell CH train for
this
[Music]
what's wrong with
Britney like that was the only the only
option that left him
yet
wait a lot of these characters have uh
their first name and their last name of
the same lighs guess a lot ofation yeah
Peter Parker Jessica Jones comic
tradition yeah even Clark Ked up the
letters dad I thought you oh my god what
white supremacist dad was that's why he
was murdered violently I'm
guessing the Girl Next
Door pervert
is this a play on is this the literally
the girl next door I think that was the
poster right the Emil hirs movie
[Music]
OHF R I'll be right
down
[Music]
yes timing is everything I am so proud
to welcome Dr Steven Hawking
oh oh I know that actor I thought it
might have been Simon Rex I cannot walk
and I use this computer to speak but I
am not depressed because I have the gift
of knowledge that's a lie brutal honesty
you can walk talk wipe your own asses
and then there's all the
sex hey anyone want to get
high white guy in the dreads you know
what I'm talking
[Music]
about I how they just cast a blonde in
their dressing her like G Stacy like the
headband and everything yeah watch where
you're going in slowo
[__] tell her how you
feel uh-oh going to break it off the
dragonfly
powers
I always love that shot in ramy's first
film yeah the Spider-Man 2099 kind of
power set
ooh damn I'm going to kill you
get yes good Riff on The Flash Thompson
Peter Parker Locker fight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
slowmo her dad's a teacher I guess that
one guy willing to be shirtless of
those
oh
oh oh no time to jump off building oh
not
yet now yeah got to climb got to climb
it first
[Music]
yep
this is what was missing in ramy's
Spider-Man film Yep this is what they
could have
been it's going to be like now oh my
back oh my
back he's got to do Sea Biscuit first ah
get out of the way no
breaks oh
no look
out
[Music]
oh like Superman powers can't believe it
you just saved that old lady's life
amazing I I guess if I had to pushed her
out of the way she would have
died you should be really proud of
yourself excuse me it's like as long as
I saved the dog I don't think I made it
in
time whoa how did you do do that it's
easier than it
looks I don't think so why don't you
tell me what's going
on he's like take me to the hospital I
think I have superpowers I find that
hard to believe all right how about this
go ahead and throw as many punches as
you want I bet you a hundred bucks you
don't land
one I was bitten by a dragonfly some
dragonflies have armored can
I well good thing that
worked so you do have superpowers we can
be a team we going to get fame money
don't forget the [__] I didn't ask
for any of this I I just want to be like
everybody else that isn't what your
parents wanted for you you're not my
father but I love you like your father
did I had with your mother just like
your
father you'll never understand me
[Music]
his dad's signant ring I'm guessing
yeah o little Batman Begins M yeah that
was 3 years before this yeah yeah
something troubling you it's so unfair
does he blame himself I love that his
parents are Batman Bruce Thomas Wayne
and Martha but also The Parkers why did
you say that name give me your wallet
Michael Papa John that's the guy who
played the actual guy yeah and
Spider-Man kerine I believe his name was
oh that's so funny you to be a hero when
that day comes will you be ready and he
was also an Amazing Spider-Man as well I
love that they got the same guy back
just kill parents yeah
right
oh
please ah it is actually his fault oh no
that looks like the same uh in The Mask
the same uh dad
oh Rick Alleyway Alleyway yeah Rick I
have something for you reach into my
coat
pocket the other coat
pocket that ring was my father's earn it
prick be a hero claim
your this kid is dangerous a very
violent
child I'm no
superhero
I
[Music]
don't oh my
god did you hear all that are you okay
what you heard
that you're nothing but an ugly
ungrateful
little mother who was that my
mother my parents they want me to go to
college I want to be a dancer I believe
in you you really do don't you I wish I
could say the same for Lance am I just
dating him to rebel against my father he
doesn't want any Boy near me that's why
he installed the electrified
fence it's funny cuz even with blonde
hair she looks more like the comic Mary
Jane than Kirsten dun like the slight
cleft to the chin the Square Face
definitely it's very like Rema
Spider-Man maybe one day you could take
me for a ride in your
car uh
yeah it's just playing off all the
tropes of Ry
Spider-Man Rick this is Xavier TR your
powers are growing but you can't control
it it's important that
you train yourself to fly in your ass
because squatting on a glass table Two
Girls One Cup oh no I understood that
reference I need to buy a car frankly Mr
rker you're the worst applicant we've
ever had thanks for the Lo Mr
Thompson there must be something I can
do rubbing my under the desk won't
change my mind I'm not rubbing your I
really need that car it was worth a
try nobody move everybody stay down get
down come on lady you hurt
o hey made the same
mistake I missed the part where that's
my problem you let him get away with our
money I don't see how that's my
problem oh no Les Neil
[Laughter]
son I thought something terrible had
happened well I know guy did get shot
over
there minimizing the importance of that
no one around him yeah Rick with great
power comes great responsibility I was
going to stick with [__]
but I like that one better greate power
cubes
[__]
oh oh so he's got to constantly suck the
life force out of
people interesting power hard to be
Shooter McGavin
yeah that's going to be a lot of bodies
you're going to have to
hide okay I come back is that Craig
Mason I think that was Craig Mason
really I think that was that would fit
like a cameo if you're writ or director
what brought you here today my uncle
your uncle brought you no he he's
Gravely injured well then he shouldn't
be
driving is my uncle going to survive
well I'm not a bing man but if you want
to put some money on it I'll take dead
in the week first my parents and now
this yes your life has been a testament
to that but your uncle believed in you
it's never too late to become the person
you're meant to be Rick
Rick oh here we go how do you know my
name I'm a
psychic my name is Professor Xavier and
this is my school I started it to help
people with special talents like yours
the students here learned to harness
their incredible talent and use them to
advance the common good
some faces may be familiar like
Wolverine yeah most of our students are
born with their
powers some like you gained them later
in life came to this school oh God take
enough roid you could do
anything I can't believe he agreed to do
that yeah must have been right as the
controversy you needed the money I mean
jeez Professor about this secret well
you see Savor oh
[__] hey a Regina Hall oh man and she
was in Scary Movie yeah
inv Anderson s take care of your man
maybe this wouldn't happen oh this [__]
is crazy I'mma have to whip your ass you
don't say no
disrespect now what now how about that
invisa
[__] invis [__] how could you do this
to me kid how do I know that baby's even
mine because he can do
this I'm never going to know the secret
of becoming a superhero you want to know
the secret Come
Close make a costume [__] exactly
this is awesome cuz I always wanted to
see Spider-Man go to Xavier school it's
like Ultimate Spider-Man X-Men crossover
yes one day maybe just like Stanley
intended in this spoof wonder if they
ever had him come on to set just for fun
I know he didn't work on this but I mean
Hugh Jackman was supposed to appear in
uh in Spider-Man but they they couldn't
get the costume through custom I did I
that I did hear that yes God I would
have freaked out in the theater I
literally would have freaked out in the
theater so ahead of its time yeah oh my
God
damn that's not bad it's got the Cyclops
but way before Cyclops how can you see
what that I assume it's
I breathe too you put some kind of air
intake in The Mask boy you
better dud I'm going tell you something
Rick this is good I'm impressed like
really
impressed there we go that makes sense
hey that's my spot you're sitting on my
gargoyle yes Simon Rex what are you even
doing here I'm looking seriously out
over the city that's what I do here so
if you're not moving I guess we're going
to have to
share what's your name John storm so
what's your power stand back flame
on I'm on
fire not working get the fire
extinguisher oh [__] once you understand
the true nature of heroism you will fly
uh you just collapse into the ground y
[__] oh even
better we got our super hero Montage
yeah with newspaper flips yes some time
what's his name
bugman a good time in superhero Cinema
newspaper Montage yeah they
were didn't expect to Tom Cruz he's not
even a hero I remember this guy I have I
have I have just very early internet
before Tik Tok celebrity he can't even
fly the dragon fly can't even
fly I can fly
okay this just in Tom Cruz is
dead couldn't fly I'm afraid you have to
kill each day to live each day unless
you had some cerillium take a look
Hawkings lab is in the physics building
you're going to steal
cerillium that me someone who will at
any cost
survive
oh glass in my eye glass in my eye oh it
was called TR Trin or in the Spider-Man
2 right the one that Doc O yeah what was
it called Trum tridium tridium tridium
sounds right I don't
remember going to have a jjon to Jameson
to me I want that story on my desk are
your oh there we go I was wondering if
you had a job opening for job how dare
you come in here and ask me for a job
I'm the editor and chief I know the
mayor of Venus hamburgers can see the
future Ros sorry about this
oh boss we nowhere on those dragonfly
photos those were tomorrow's lead what
about these wow just in his room it's
almost like you're the dragonfly uh no
no no see
look just heard on the scanner some kind
of police standoff at Empire University
we'll need photos kid I want you to
where'd he go he's definitely not him no
couldn't
be DAV this is the chief of police we
have the building surrounded one of the
coolest voices to ever voice oh yeah
what the hell is
that oh wow that's pretty cool I Am The
Hourglass your time is
up
[Music]
s is it I'll fight you to my last
breath un ceasing andless EV will never
trium sour
glass be stop stop stop yelling
catchphrases yeah great are you okay
no yeah we got dizzy too from that shot
titanium blades they cut through
diamonds I'm not wearing any
[Laughter]
Diamonds oh yes this shot that was from
Spider-Man one that was great I wish I
could stay longer
dragonfly but I just don't have the
time it's so corny but I love it oh and
that's how he's going to identify the
cut just like Goblin at the Thanksgiving
dinner we're getting Thanksgiving
whoever this dragonfly is he's in over
his head we don't need So-Cal superhero
what Empire City needs is more cops and
a
Hooters amen Jill I heard your
auditioning for parts so God you are so
supportive I can't Lance be more like
you there's something you're not telling
me isn't there there is keep your
identity a secret
uh nothing well I should go
tiger uhoh Spider-Man 2 scene wait no
where the rain comes yeah the Street's
already wet
yeah seems like again the same Alleyway
from when 100% they probably show it the
same day yeah this is all on universal
Backlot but they're not hiding
[Applause]
[Music]
it oh
oh
[Music]
yes the rain okay we got to get the
upside down kiss how do you get upside
down where are you behind
you it's a fire escape door uh ladder I
get to thank
you oh my
God
yeah
[Music]
yeah cuz that's what happened to kren
Dun in that scene you could clearly see
them in the rain that's so
[Music]
funny damn just did the math I'm so Happ
oh here's our Thanksgiving scene yes
Thanksgiving with us of course Lucille
we didn't realize how seasly appropriate
this film was yeah all right seeing my
Albert each morning 50 years of marriage
creates quite a bond I wish I knew love
like that oh you will dear they didn't
have enough prop celery to let her cut
it so she's just pressing each of them
who can you trust I know but what if my
heart is telling me to be with someone
what what hey babe I forgot to tell you
I kind of invited my uncle your uncle is
that another plate is it well okay I
guess Johnson I had a feeling I was
about to say is that where is
Rick what that on I thought he was out
I'll go check on him you're busy allow
me thank
you
damn yeah I would imagine you'd have to
really go to the restroom after that
Rick going to do the blood dropping but
it's going to be P oh pee
you got yeah good call good
call yep yep you go
that oh I feel his pain I've had that
happen before just not on the ceiling or
in a super suit I assume but hey I your
[Music]
lifestyle
[Laughter]
sprinkler settings is
great those Elfin swells are great yeah
sorry I'm late oh Mr
Landers
not to we say grace Jesus amen I think
I've seen a gift of that before of the
stab this I think so Rick has been
supporting me with his new job you
didn't tell me I'm sort of the
dragonfly's unofficial photographer
uh-oh oh what happened to your arm a
bike messenger knocked me
down I see your wrist is bandaged I
bured on some hot coffee we have to go
why I shut my
pants you know the dragonfly I I guess
has he ever asked about me yeah once
what did you tell him I told him the
thing about Jill is when you look in her
eyes and she looks back in yours
[Music]
you if you were ever lucky enough to be
with
her you could earn every second of her
[Music]
perfect and her unending ending love
don't cry I'm not my eyes are burning
understandable I want you to know that
was the most beautiful thing anyone's
ever said to
me God it's understandable after that
turkey she made Rick I'm so confused and
yet somehow somehow I didn't see that
one
[Music]
coming peeled off the
wallpaper Green Goblin moment hourglass
this is the lair of the dragonfly finish
it this little visit is just to show you
who will get hurt if you get in my
[Music]
way time to
go she can't speak she can't walk she
has no control over her bowels that's
that's awful I know I went ahead and set
up a MySpace page for her under crazy
[__] machine Myspace simpler times yeah
in that Facebook Myspace crossover she's
dead truly sorry Rick your uncle came
out of his coma this morning you mustn't
tell him about your aunt just yet he's
in a delicate mental state the slightest
bit of bad news could send him right
back into a coma also to that same year
with Iron Man he said I don't want to
see this on your Myspace yeah is it
Lucille no sir it's it's not your dead
wife it's your nephew it's not your dead
wife don't tell him we are gathered
today to say goodbye to Lucille Adams
oh instead of Uncle Ben it was Aunt May
yeah we get that seed that way LESA
Nelson's anymore H how could you take
her from
me sorry there's been a terrible mistake
this is your wife ah she is this man's
wife
give me five
[Music]
minutes oh oh I am so sorry for your
loss I know I said some things but we
can never be together you love me Rick I
know you do Jill trust me I'm telling
you this for your own
good I don't love you you're no longer
in my
five that joke is for a very specific AG
right you're no longer in my
five God look at this place look at you
eating junk food wearing fake
beards I wish I'd never been bitten by
that stupid dragonfly and maybe your
father shouldn't have given you this
after all look at the words your
ancestors inscribed in that ring honor
Valor Duty commitment
bravery even if I wanted to stop Stop
The Hourglass I wouldn't know where to
start I mean where's he going to find
thousands of people in one place from
the Empire City Convention Center it's
such a Trope seeing the answer on the
news on TV the TV that is playing what
you need yeah the world Humanity
Awards well that shortcut to the
playground sure saved us some
time our first award is for the medical
breakthrough of the year I have leanders
dece bag of the year
[Music]
[Applause]
stop right there
Landers you know you're damn right I do
you're the douchebag of the Year someone
in this Auditorium is The Hourglass I
need your help to figure out who it
is did see a man with what looked like a
canister of cerillium
who
the dolly
Lama know the world the armor you're
hiding under these Ro you can't fool me
hourglass you're pecking 10 lb of
cerillium under
there oh not Nelson Mandela pleas
[__] all peace until you get hit by a
bread roll
[Music]
you you're The
Hourglass did he take her hostage or
you'll never get away with this forget
it dragonfly you're too
late ow
oh goodbye little fly
oh
noly
no
[Music]
oh dragonfly you must stop The Hourglass
I can't fly if there is one lesson my
life can teach it is that the spirit is
stronger than the body those are SEL
Dion
[Music]
lyrics
where am I you're with me your
lover what the Spider-Man set with Green
Goblin he's got to like land seated near
there no only now do you
[Music]
understand oh
no
oh it's over
dragonly
chill oh here we
go got you just fall like Rick you
didn't think I'd let anything happened
to the girl I love did you I don't care
what happens anymore if I die I die
happily in your arms you're my hero Rick
reer and I love
you
yeah because of you our city is safe at
last you said it Dr Hawkins oh
no let's go get some dinner on buying
that kind of reminded me did you see
naked gun yeah in the first one he hit
OJ Simpson he went down uh within the
wheelchair will forever be a
[Music]
superher oh
God we going to get a mid credits after
scene they weren't as popular but maybe
oh God from the creator of The Last of
Us show and Chernobyl and
Chernobyl comes superhero
movie that was quick
too pretty quick I love that Craig Barco
got a wolver in credit for that 30
seconds
yeah what a miles fiser was that guy's
name yeah he was like a the one of the
first internet celebrity like YouTube
era impressionist yeah I remember that
but I yeah I just love how this film
just plays off of so many trps and
clearly Ramy Remy Spider-Man was uh the
biggest uh thing that they were going
the guy doesn't even name it's okay I
come back Craig B yeah yeah okay yeah
I've seen him in so many interviews with
uh The Last of Us I was like I hope I
recognize I was like Craig Mason um but
yeah I just love all the the superhero
tropes that they were playing off of in
this I'm actually surprised it didn't go
uh it did you know touched on X-Men but
this was post Daredevil post Ghost Rider
fantastic it did get Fantastic 4 like a
couple you know a little a little bit
there but it was very singularly
Spider-Man yeah blade even too as
well and uh then you had blade one two
and three had just uh 2004 yeah so yeah
they didn't really play off blade but
yeah like the Ry Spider-Mans were the
ones that they were but I mean for
someone like me who obviously as
everyone always points out in every
video uh loves superhero references I
love all the references that they made
in this film and all the tropes they
were going off of and such a for someone
who's such a big fan of spoofs as well
you know from Scary Movie Naked Gun all
those I thought this film just uh I just
I love the humor in this I was surprised
to see it had such a I know films are
all subjective I was surprised to see it
had such a low rating on IMDb I mean
it's not the greatest spoof in the world
but it's my type of humor I just uh yeah
I thought it was I thought it was pretty
funny uh what' you think uh I'm not like
a spoof guy I I remember I like the
scary movies when I was younger I have
I've risked re-watching them uh because
it's just not like I I really struggle
with comedies like I I personally think
of Comedy as being like Lethal Weapon or
in Brugge or Kiss Kiss Bang Bang like
that's comedy banshees Sharon I like
banshees so much that search light like
kept inviting me back cuz I was
basically their laugh track like that's
more my comedy but when I was younger
this was more my like you know
sensibility and I definitely think of
scary movie as being like the spoofs I
enjoyed uh I did love Naked Gun as a kid
and there were some moments like
especially the Leslie neelen that that
lend itself to it um but the uh the I
think scary movie was definitely scream
Centric but it did seem to Branch out
into more of the topical time of the era
oh got
something my dad says my breasts are too
big for a dancer maybe he's right I mean
look at them they're
just Dr talking I'd love to show you my
project on supernovas you have an
incredible astronomy career ahead of
you oh the yes catching in the food tray
yes wait the only CGI in the movie like
or the
main what if I killed 28 people in one
session would that give me a month to
live if it were February
yes I'll just get to my back to you but
a knockoff you can have it on the way
out Old McDonald had a farm and Bingo
was his name up and uh that's
[Music]
uh people thr some crazy douchebag but
hit by a douchebag award and the credits
that same guy who wipes over's ass and I
was wondering what that meant we're a
team what do they call you call me the
incredible
black
in 2003 Mr Landers won the National
Science award for his invention of the
non-stick toilet seat that thing saved
my grandma
life excuse me there is a
line so unfair they have nothing why do
we have2
billion I've got tomorrow's editorial
when you sleep with someone you're
sleeping with everyone they ever slept
with does that make you gay yes yes see
die well someone will think twice before
they try to steal a pack of gun from you
again was worth all the damage for
[Music]
that dang
it God weird format at I think that was
about like 8 minutes of credits for an
hour and 20 minute movie I wonder if it
ran too short to be a feature length fil
yeah cuz usually what they usually hit
the 90 minute Mark right I think 82 is
is minimum to be feat right I don't
think I've ever seen that much at the
end there like that where it was like
necessary well yeah usually like in a in
a Jackie Chan film you usually see what
like like spoof and and you'll have I
mean you'll have um like bloopers and
stuff but it's usually while the credits
are running and then a little bit that
was like a chunk of a good that was
interesting I don't think I've ever seen
that format but I was saying I do think
this hits The Sweet Spot and I do think
um what's tricky is the tone of Comedy
shifts uh you know the early 2000s was
like the runchy comedy with your
American pies and your um you know sex
comedies and stuff and the late 200 like
as heading into the teens was like appat
was
thriving and so like I just don't think
the spoof Market was as strong as it was
in the early ODS like that was I think
scary movie came out in what like 01 uh
the first one was 2000 the second one
was 2001 so it was like that was the
time they were thriving in those earlies
and this is' 08 this is when things are
shifting more appau this is um you know
obviously the superhero movie stuff's
about to go insane yes but uh I I think
that's probably why you were saying you
know like the IMB and stuff were low I
think it's just um you know I again I
can I can see that this isn't my type of
Comedy but I can still see that if it
was this would be that but I think that
audience had shifted yeah yeah no for
sure I mean I was into spoof so I don't
know why I missed this one I mean but
like you said at in this year I mean you
had Iron Man you had Dark Knight come
out so I surprised I picked those two
over this one but still um choices what
were you doing right I know I missed
opportunities but you know I'm glad I
got to react to it with you yeah 15
years later like it it arrived exactly
as it should like a wizard when it's now
a c in cold status but uh I I do love
all like I said all the tropes and stuff
that it played I think one of my
favorite tropes that it played off of
amongst many was like that TV one that
was great that's like always something
that's always bothered me in films like
I mean there's so many things in films
I'm like that's perfect timing like
usually when someone walks and when you
know someone's about to kiss someone
then the other person walks in or
something but that that TV one when like
the the pertinent information you need
to find out we need blah blah blah oh
volume up and it's always a volume up
and you see the volume go up like you
see yeah that's how it works in real
life when you need to know something
really important at that specific time
it's really it's right on the TV knew
today's lottery numbers oh exactly
exactly uh I also think they did a good
job like it's always so sincere in
movies it was it was really that
particular thing was handled really well
here because it wasn't like as
cartoonish as a lot of the other jokes
so it it made you go like well [__] that
is annoying like I like when spoofs do
the more subtle as well as the Absurd
like throwing you know uh what's his
name off a building Etc like yeah um
yeah I I like some of the credit jokes
were some of my favorites actually the
uh we need to identify this body that's
why it's going to be so difficult that's
such a great that actually is like a I
think of that like a Leslie neelson line
but like well delivered by Tambour but a
lot a lot of the credit stuff was solid
um overall had fun it was great to
revisit you know what founded this genre
we love for sure it was great to think
on Spider-Man and X-Men and all those
things yeah fantastic for and uh I mean
obviously too like we said the Remy I
would say the first and second movie
were big you know points of interest
here terms of what they were trying to
go off of in terms of the storyline the
character stuff uh yeah tiny bit of
Batman Begins which I thought was great
uh obviously fantastic for with our two
cameos finally we got to see Marvel and
DC together guys it's the first time
we've seen Spider-Man at X-Men at
Xavier's Mansion yes yes no that was
cool to see that and uh yeah no overall
I I enjoyed this it was fun I actually
you know I thought I mean overall the
acting was great just from everyone it
was a really strong cast I wasn't I did
not actually look other than Bell I
didn't really look up the cast I only
Drake Bell because the opening uh like
screen yeah but uh I was uh I was really
I was really uh surprised by how good
the acting was because usually with
spoofs it's it can be hit or miss you
know uh just because of the tone and
everything with that heart surprised me
which one young Kevin Hart oh yeah that
was Hiser I mean I guess what he was
supposed to be his his har Harry Osborne
ask yeah the best friend yeah um so that
wasy I think and no I think the cousin
the girl the boyfriend was probably the
Harry Osborne oh with the flat he was
like FL com they had Norman his be his
uncle right so I think that was kind of
like the bully best friend Rich Kid
guess yeah I guess you could call uh uh
Kevin Hart like maybe uh what Ned uh
that's in like the ultimate that's what
they've made you know miles morales's
Ganky into Ned yeah um okay yeah so I
guess he would be man Spider-Man didn't
really have a best friend that it was
actually his friend cuz Harry Osborne
just kind of used him well cuz Ned
becomes hot in the comics hgin yeah but
like I feel like actually going to
school like no one would ride the bus
with Peter yeah yeah cuz uh you know
Harry be taking his Porsche and then
like flash you know hated him until they
got out of high school and they realized
you know the Redemption Arc sorry now
I'm thinking about comic books I'm like
wondering who Peter Parker would have
considered his best friend growing up uh
but yeah I I had fun um I'm glad to have
now seen it uh definitely not my general
you know sensibility but like seeing
Simon Rex who's like a classic from
Scary Movie again um some of the Staples
having uh Pam Anderson and that uh the
car Electra kind of Ro yeah and again if
I had not seen that Craig Amon had
directed this so confused when never
yeah I would not that that too I would
have been like what what is what is
happening but also too at the end seeing
that he wrote and directed it again I
still I still thought it was pretty good
but I just I would have been really
shocked to have seen that even though I
was when I saw that before we had
watched it sure but then like actually
seeing it on was like wow that is is
surprising I think the biggest lesson
here for everyone at home that goes
blank is making blank oh my God they
made blank maybe you wait and see the
movie because if I was a huge Last of Us
fan and I had been like oh my God the
creator of superhero movie is making
Last of Us and I judged it I would have
been like oh but range yeah and
evolution it's true true I mean it's so
insane how people judge 100% on the
prior when you like haven't seen the
property yeah I have no idea if they
ever made a sequel to this cuz I know
obviously we know they made there's like
five scary movies yeah we know they made
I was just about to say that um but
having where we've uh you know gone into
with superhero films now from where this
film was in 2008 I'd love to see I I
mean I I I highly doubt Craig Mason
would want to do this again but um
whoever I would love to see you know
them do 15 years later yeah just I mean
because where we again where we're at
today with superhero films I mean
there's been quite an evolution since
I'd love to see you know um you know not
not it doesn't have to be obviously a
Peter Parker Centric film but just I
mean just from they probably go Iron Man
they it today I could yeah I could see I
could definitely see infity Saga te mov
yeah you could do such a riff on the MCU
I mean there's so I mean even even the D
you could do something just making fun
of them rushing the DCU I mean there's
there's so much material that you could
do with I mean cuz again like we said
the focus here was clearly on one and
two with Spider-Man one and with Ries so
I mean there's just so much material in
there you could even make fun of them
doing uh you know three different
Spider-Man at there's just so much
material you could you could even have
them go oh three different people I
there's just so much material you could
have in there so I'd be fascinated if
someone would be interested in doing
that and I mean I'd love to see that for
sure and if you liked this I highly
recommend it's on the screen right now
watch mysterymen it is so good I've
never seen mystery I think I've seen one
I think I've seen one or two minutes of
that but I've never never I've never SE
I think the only line I've seen is hey
maybe you should put some clothes on if
you want to fight crime like that that's
the only line I've I saw it theaters
three times I was like a team
superhero I know Greg can I mean
obviously Ben still those and but I know
I've never seen that one I've seen I've
seen blank man though it was one of my
first DVDs I bought with my own money I
remember saving up to buy M DVDs used to
be like 28 bucks and I remember like
saving for mysterymen okay I I will
check if you
guys if you want him to watch Myster com
below yes have you seen Sky High by the
way uh I have I really enjoy I didn't
see it until like three years ago it was
a a great one I love that movie so much
Sky High too I I could see happening
it's time but if you want him to watch
mysterymen you want me to watch uh I
don't know there's very few we were
talking before there's very few super
movies I hav't seen I haven't seen
punish war zone somehow inex or League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen those my last
two I I haven't seen League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen either if you
want us to watch League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen you want him to watch mrman
maybe John hasn't seen it I think GRE
has then let us know in the comments
below hit that like in the way out thank
you for being here thank you to our
patrons for watching this front to back
beginning to end thank you to all of
reject Nation again leave a comment
leave a like share this Etc so much love
we'll see you soon
[Music]
Rejects